population collapse is a terrifying
thing if if you think about it
the only reason I have a cell phone
right now that can pull up videos and do
all this crazy stuff is because there's
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people who know how to do
each and every one of these little
things to make it right there's a person
who Minds the raw materials the rare
Earths the metals who uh there's a
company that makes the glass yeah so
it's not you know like apple makes it or
Android makes it then there's a company
that makes the chips there's a company
that makes the cameras it all comes
together into this device
if the glass company ceases to exist
touch screens are gone like what do you
get plastic screen maybe with buttons If
the rare Earths are gone well now we got
to Source them from somewhere else we
can't get that if we lose access to
these specialty positions I'll tell you
if there's a population collapse we will
lose more than people realize because it
is only because of the massive
population that we're able to have such
highly refined and Powerful tools
Specialties as there's more more and
more people there's finer and finer
Specialties you go back 500 years
actually you go back thousands of years
it was possible to as one as a single
person to know everything humans knew
just being one person like because there
was so little knowledge now there's so
much knowledge there's no way one person
could actually manufacture a cell phone
by themselves let alone a toaster that
famous Ted Talk where a guy says I tried
to make a toaster from scratch this is
what it'll be like if population
collapse happens it'll be a hundred
years from now you'll have a kid and
you'll be telling a story about how we
used to have small devices they were
like cards and you'd touch it and you
could make images appear you could
control people on the screen on the
screen you can move them around you knew
where it was raining around the world
you could talk to anyone around the
planet those kids are going to be like
that's magic yeah you're gonna be an old
person like I swear we had this thing
look and there will be like relics of it
and the kids are like how do you even
use it how does it even turn on I'm like
well the Network's gone the technology
is gone we lost it all forget about this
and to them they'll hear the story and
then they'll tell their kids magic and
then in 50 years 60 years the kids are
going to be alike they used to believe
in magic so dumb yeah I know forget
about the luxuries the medical
implications are also going to be very
vast because there's not going to be
enough young people to take care of the
old people there's going to be so many
horrible effects especially when it
comes to the larger economic system
which is going to collapse especially
with the lack of people since of course
economies grow with people less people
less growth bigger collapse Japan is a
good yes for all of this because first
of all Japan is one of the lowest if not
the lowest fertility rates all the
places with the lowest fertility rates
seem to be the most technologically
advanced but then other than you know
the west and European countries that
seem to have attempted to solve this
problem by importing massive amount of
people from the developing World Japan
has decided it to develops robots to
replace them which may in the end turn
out to have been a better choice we you
just don't know
um so I don't think so well China is
also doing something very similar they
have very weird robots that we can't
talk about on the show that I brought up
before that everyone here knows about
but but China also is is facing a huge
democratulations these Boston Dynamics
robots they're terrifying and I've been
on good authority that actually there's
an ulterior motive there is that
actually the Boston Dynamics robots are
secretly programmed for a future in
which it is a state law that everybody
has to watch Alex Friedman videos
the Boston Dynamic robots will come
you have to watch at least three per
month
the Boston Dynamic robot shows up at
your house and then a screen comes out
and Alexa have you seen that I mean
you're being chased the dogs are running
after you with screens on their back and
you're like and they pin you down and it
just plays I don't want to listen
meanwhile Alex is just talking to you
quietly well I don't what it's like you
guys don't like Lex Friedman's show or
what I think he's fine I think it's
fascinating I nothing for or against but
I think it's
safe to say it's fair to say that this
is the most algorithmically driven
phenomenon on the entire internet I hear
so many stories of saying I went to bed
watching this on YouTube and I woke up
and Lex Friedman was on it's like all
paths lead to Friedman and it's a very
interesting thing you wonder sometimes
how these uh phenomena occur
um maybe he's just such a great
charismatic interviewer that it's just
manifestly obvious why he would you know
be elevated to such a station with so
many uh interesting guests maybe there
are other factors but I I definitely
think
um it's
you know I really think the Boston
Dynamic robots they're they're made to
enforce it maybe there's going to be a
scotus decision just like the Obamacare
they can force you to buy health
insurance they can force you to watch
the Friedman videos
um there are all sorts of possibilities
in the future I always get recommended
to him all the time and I'm like no I
just don't want to like all the time
non-stop did they fall asleep watching
Lex Friedman or do they end up on Lex
Freedom that's also a good question to
to think they well there you go no no
disrespect Lex it's all good he's just
spreading love but it's nothing against
him but it is weird it is the most
algorithmically driven thing on the
entire internet remember that story
about that uh that chick who lived in
the van she put up two YouTube videos
and then got millions of subscribers
it was uh it exposes that there is
absolutely an algorithm driving
everything and controlling what you what
you see and uh my conspiracy theory is
that the van life trend on YouTube was
to try and convince Millennials to not
buy stuff and to live in a pod right and
live in the body the bugs eat the bugs
and and not own anything because people
can't own homes now it's you know their
parents are telling them hey you should
say about money and own a home that's
not possible for the average person
nowadays with the salaries that they're
having with how much uh you know the
price of real estate has increased
that's impossible but you could have a
van by the river right or you could have
some uh you know cryptocurrencies you
could have some tether right right
Darren yeah do we have time together
watch some watch some Lex buy some
tethers you know get into little
geometric Unity Theory there you go do
we have time to talk about that uh your
article because you wrote a very
interesting article just the short and
like you know like Tim said there's been
a lot of talk about tether for a long
time but this piece that's up on my news
site revolver.news it's generating a lot
of Buzz and crypto world and otherwise
and I'll just lay out the basic data
points and people can kind of decide for
themselves uh it's a very weird story
it's the third largest cryptocurrency in
existence it's a stable coin meaning
that its value is not it's not mined in
the way that Bitcoin is or ethereum
that's its value allegedly comes from US
dollar reserves backing the tether
it's never been fully or properly
audited in its entire existence which is
weird given that its whole value is
based on the fact that it allegedly has
these reserves and then if you look at
the cast of characters behind tether one
of them is a washed up child Disney
actor called Brock Pierce who was
involved in all sorts of things a weird
sort of underage sex scandal that he got
embroiled in he was apprehended by
Interpol in Spain there is allegedly
child pornography and all this stuff
involved in the apprehension he was not
arrested weirdly and then he turns up as
the founder of this major cryptocurrency
which is a stable coin which has never
been audited which defies the U.S
treasury treasury in in various respects
and which just happens to be the
official cryptocurrency of several U.S
backed Rebel groups
geopolitically including the rohingya
rebel groups in Myanmar and so the
thesis
a deuced in this piece suggests that
there could be an historical antecedent
to the function that tether May uh
fulfill and that is the BCCI bank which
is this Bank set up by the CCA or the
CIA uh to facilitate all kinds of money
laundering operations and so forth
but the cast of characters is really
remarkable here of course there's a
Jeffrey Epstein connection and so I
encourage everyone to go and look at it
and for crypto enthusiasts and experts I
welcome feedback from where you know are
we barking up the wrong tree or not but
so far I've received extremely positive
feedback from the crypto community in
terms of tether being uh the the Highly
Questionable proposition the issue with
so many cryptocurrencies they're clearly
scams and there's that uh that that
Alameda woman Beckman Freed's girlfriend
who I think she said something like
crypto is just scams or something else
like it's like she's like it's all scams
and right something else or whatever and
like drugs or something crypto is I
think mostly scams but that's not uh to
disrespect crypto itself it's that well
everything's pretty much a scam these
days what isn't a scam yeah the issue is
that there are people who are using
crypto2 scam but there are absolutely
amazing and legitimate cryptocurrencies
and Technology itself is incredible
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time